ils ont retrouvé les sensations de la
ride en reprenant le chemin des pistes
pour les entraînements de bmx au stadium
de st quentin en yvelines et cyclistes
sont ravis de pouvoir à nouveau pédaler
après deux mois d'arrêt ça fait du bien
rester long confinement ne ferais ça
fait du bien de pouvoir pour faire du
sport à travers plaisir quand même
quelques investigations
elle peut - on est moins nombreux un
petit plouf de dit c'est ouais c'est par
intervalles on ne peut pas il ya eu tous
les jours comme vous voulez avant même
si l'engouement est total pour les
riders la reprise se fait dans un
premier temps en douceur les
compétitions qui ont été reportés
reprendront en septembre avec des coupes
d'europe et championnat de france
aujourd'hui wailly vitrail beaucoup les
départs et la première ligne droite
bah après aussi des courses qui nous est
qu'ils ont été reportés en oeuvre à
partir de septembre jusqu'à on va dire
décembre on aboutit à des courses qui
sont qui vont venir donc oui je
conseille travail va retravailler
l'accélération se remettre dedans
gentiment pour respecter les règles
sanitaires le stadium a réduit le nombre
de cyclistes sur les pistes passant de
50 riders à seulement 10 du
professionnel aux débutants tout le
monde peut quand même s'exercer en
respectant la distanciation physique on
a différentes consignes différents
protocoles qu'on doit appliquer de
manière stricte c'est aussi notre
volonté on a évidemment l'ambition de
rouvrir nos activités indoor
maintenant il faut savoir qu'on n'a plus
tôt l'ambition de favoriser nos
pratiques outdoor autour du vélo mais on
en parle mais on en parle on essaye de
mettre tout ce qu'on peut mettre en
oeuvre pour rouvrir l'intérieur du
vélodrome
des baptêmes de bmx ont proposé tous les
samedis pour l'instant l'équipe du
vélodrome favorise l'extérieur en
attendant que l'intérieur ne rouvre la
date du 22 juin est en partie révoquée